please let me tell you about this game
okay hear me out you need to hear about
what they've done this is a picture of
Co-op Rog likee game ink bound that
comes from an indie Dev it's already
kind of popular but it's not like a
juggernaut which makes what they've done
even more impressive and I just everyone
just go download this game just to show
support developer shiny shoe decided to
remove all
monetization from the game it is already
in Steam Early Access so monetization
was there but they've removed it citing
industry and player sentiment meaning
they literally removed them for no
reason other than people don't like them
it's not that it was buggy it's not that
they had to change the economy it's not
that they're bringing them back they
just recognized that people think it
sucks which same and took them out they
had a battle pass and an in-game shop
and those were initially included to
support the game's development which it
I'm sure it has helped you can still get
the Cosmetic items that they had in game
via playing but nothing can be purchased
and I love this